When you came full circle and like the pandemic started
and you have two young children.
Yes.
What was that like?
Yeah, it was a rough time,
and it was why I wrote the book.
We were sitting around with the pandemic,
and George Floyd had been murdered,
and there was anti-Asian violence erupting,
and the kids were under foot
and we were just sort of searching for a way
to explain it all to them.
And as a result, I started thinking about another incident
of police brutality when I was younger,
the Rodney King beating.
And so I started thinking about the immigrant journey also,
like what is this country that I thought I was coming to,
and what is it now, and all this.
And so the book is about a boy,
a bit of a troublemaker, who comes home, he's suspended.
And his parents own a liquor store in South Central L.A.
And it's April 29th, 1992,
the day the verdict is being read.
The father goes to the store to board it up.
And the boy, seeing the news reports,
grows increasingly desperate
and decides that the best way to protect his father
is to take his dad's gun from the closet
and deliver it to him for protection that night.
So it's a poor decision,
but an interesting story as the boy
tries to get across Los Angeles.
And is it true that your sons read it?
Yes, yeah.
And like contributed
to like compliments?
Or did you run it by them?
Yeah, he was my authenticity reader at the end.
I was like, "How'd I do, how'd I do?"
And he said, "Good job, Daddy."
What did your parents like think?
I mean, you moved here from Korea at a young age.
Did they instill like their honest life to you
and life lessons about your future?
What did they think when you told them
you wanted to be an actor?
When I told them I wanted to be an actor,
I think they were just really worried
that I was going to be found dead
in an apartment from starvation, you know?
And they were just worried
that I wouldn't be able to pay the bills.
My dad did say, "You wanna become an actor?"
And this is the '90s, so I think all he saw
was Connie Chung on television.
And he said, "Maybe you wanna read the news?
Is that somewhere you wanna go?"
And I said, "That's not what I wanna do."
But I can see the logic.
That was an Asian lady.
And I think he just didn't feel
that there were any opportunities for Asians on television.
Did you ever get their stamp of approval?
I did, because when I was in the,
there was a small feature in the local Korean newspaper.
That's when I had made it in their eyes.
See, isn't that beautiful?
Yeah.
Well, speaking of actors and films and movies,
we were just chatting all things Oscars.
Do you have any favorites this year?
The one that stood out to me,
and I still have to do my viewing, is "King Richard."
And I think Will Smith has never been better.
I just have to say, as one human to another,
I really am like one of your biggest fans
and I'm so excited that you've come on the show!
(audience clapping)
I love you!
John Cho, get your copy of "Troublemaker."
It's in stores now!
(upbeat music)